i'm going to mcdonald's congratulations
on j
lo beauty jennifer whenever i interview
you i think that the one question that i
get the most from
viewers or even like friends and family
is what is her skin like up close
and you know is that the question you
get the most about your your skin and
the jayla
made a skincare line because it is you
know we'll talk about music movies this
that and wherever i go people be like
what are you doing for your skin i'm
like
okay so i really felt an obligation
almost to if i was gonna
go into beauty that the skin care would
have to be
first and foremost and so that was kind
of the idea i've actually been thinking
about this for about 20 years
benny have talked about it so many times
i think i needed to get to a place where
i had enough experience
um where i where i was kind of more
fully realized in myself to have a
really
philosophy about beauty and about beauty
from the inside out
and what that means and what it meant to
me and the idea of beauty having no
expiration date
you know you get to a certain age and
then you know people ready to kind of
like
you next bye-bye you know and you're
like hold on i'm still
finished yet on right now
as women people are so ready to write us
off i just kept waiting for that to
happen
and then i realized no i'm not gonna let
that happen and and that you can look
great you know there was a whole
bunch of stuff like yo she's this age
she's that age she did a birthday tour
but
she looks great for that age and it's
like yeah i don't think anybody wants
that
everybody wants to go you just look
great
so jlo beauty is is about that it's
about
feeling great looking great having the
healthiest skin you can have
and how do you keep that youthful and
timeless look at any age
it's about being limitless it's about
being powerful
and understanding beauty really doesn't
have an expiration date
so how did you manage then to bottle
that glow
yeah so that took that took a minute
because again i
we we literally have a product called
that j-lo glow
uh-huh which is this one which is the
cirrup serum
oh that's so pretty it's gorgeous and i
will send you some
we we have like what i call the kind of
s's the secret right so it's like
supplements serum a sunscreen
and sleep and then living healthy which
in spanish is sun
so those the combination of those and
these
products and again it took us maybe
26 different formulations like i kept
sending it back they were like how about
this the first time i'm like
no and i thought they thought well we
revise it once or twice and we'll get
there
26 iterations later i'm like we got it
it took it took a minute to really
get it to the standard that i felt like
i could put on the bottle
that jlo glow it had to you have to put
it on
it had to give you a glow it had to
tighten it had to make you feel
something but then over time
i wanted it to be super healthy for your
skin so as you kept
taking it with the supplement i call it
a pump and a pill
you take the pot you pump of the serum
and the veil and and through that
you will have this this this glowing
skin
you know over time and uh and and also
get an immediate reaction from an
immediate kind of a you you'll see it
right away when you use the serum
some of it is genetics with you too
because we see your mama
what do you think yeah she gets it from
her mama but what do you think that emmy
would say
like is your beauty wisdom that you've
given to
her you know i think it's about at the
end of the day
beauty starts from the inside out and i
always i always tell her that
um you can be youthful and timeless at
every age it's it's how you feel
about yourself on the inside so that
self-love and beauty company being about
self-care
as well as is a form of self-love you
know when you go into the mirror
and you kind of you know wash that face
and you wash things away and you just
take time and you take your little
rollers and you know i don't know if you
use those things but
i mentioned my whole routine you know
when we launch
and i'll show you the things that i do
um but when you do that it's kind of
like letting the bad thoughts go away
it's kind of like
just kind of taking a moment for
yourself to say you know i'm taking care
of you
i'm gonna be your little keeper right
now and we're gonna we're gonna get
ready for the day and we're gonna
we're gonna have an amazing day and
you're amazing and i think those things
are the things i try to teach
my my girls is like you have to feel
great about yourself
first so then you can be great for
everybody else it's about being powerful
it's about realizing your own
value and that's for me what jlo beauty
is about
being loving to yourself alex posted uh
this the other day he said you guys had
come from dinner he was about to get a
massage and you were up in the gym
at work it wasn't in work so i wonder
because we know you take such good care
of yourself but
what is your indulgence when you decide
like i'm just gonna
indulge i do i do i love having like
i love like the other night after the
american music awards i went to
mcdonald's
you know i was like i'm going to
mcdonald's because i've been like really
good these past few weeks getting ready
for my first performance in a long time
since
you know the quarantine and uh you know
so i was working out every day that's
why you know i went up to the gym that
night and
i was um you know in dance rehearsals
and then singing
you know the song the whole thing right
and well afterwards i was just like i'm
gonna go
i haven't had mcdonald's in about three
years maybe longer
and i was like i'm gonna go have
mcdonald's that's what i'm gonna do
first of all you made me fall in love
with you even more by saying that
after you snatch our wigs with maluma
you go have
a big mac come on man anyway by the way
benny drove me i was like benny
hopping at the drive-through who okay
what does the drive-through person think
when jennifer lopez and vinnie medina
wrote
adventures you know pretty did he know
that benny's just like a double
cheeseburger meal
they didn't even see us i was just like
lots of ketchup
by the way uh your performance with
maluma why did you want to do
um marry me with him and what does he
bring to the table because that
performance was hot i love it
thank you thank you so much you know um
marry me which is the movie that maluma
and i did together
out next year i think it's may 14th
right now you know everything has been
so fluid with with everything in the
theaters and not being open
and open and all that kind of stuff but
right now it's from next year may 14th
it's called marry me and uh he he just
does bring we needed a super we needed
an international superstar
and i think a lot of names came up like
adam levine or drake or john mayer and
like any of them could have played the
part but i was like why don't we get a
latino why don't we get like the
global international superstar and i
bought up maluma's name
and i was like do you guys know who
maluma is and
uh you know some people did some people
didn't you know that we were producing
and doing the movie with
and the director and everybody and then
they they met him and
everybody fell in love with him and i i
just thought like i wanted to make a
i really wanted to make a spanglish
album an english and spanish album
because i feel like that's something
that hasn't been done
for a mainstream american movie um so
that was part of the the reason and he
was a perfect person to deal with and we
had great musical chemistry
um and uh and we wound up even doing
more songs after the movie which were
the two that we performed
on sunday at the amas which wound up one
of the mondo being in the film as well
has driven us all a little crazy your
fans as well because with the projects
you have coming up marry me
and then you're um teaming up with uh
with uh armhammer and shotgun wedding
everyone's saying is jennifer trying to
give us a message like are her and alex
gonna elope
like what is gonna happen because it's
so fun people are digging deep jennifer
your life does reflect uh into the
things that you're doing at times
but it's just kind of a coincidence it
wasn't like when i did el amigo
and i did you know the song that i did
in spanish which was like
when are you going to give me a ring i
wasn't really trying to send a message
it's just like a song that we
wrote that we liked and then um
you know with marry me it's something
that we were producing
i mean we were developing for like had
to be like seven years
wow get it right and at the right studio
and all that kind of stuff and then
like it's happening now when you know
where
you know alex and i are you know engaged
and about to get married at some point
so um yeah it just it just happens that
way it's it's a funny thing
life and art the way they kind of
intersect
[Applause]
they just announced the weekend's gonna
perform at the super bowl any advice for
him stepping on the world's largest
stage since you just did it good luck
it was it was it was intense it was
intense for me
um and it was it was all worth it in the
end
but the write itself is intense it's
funny i spoke to um
a friend of ours uh benny and i who
manages another big artist who did um
the super bowl at one time a few years
back and
uh and was like it was the most
stressful time he was like
benny was like he was like what happened
he was like you know we almost quit on
each other like we it was the only time
in
[ __ ] years that we quit on each other
and uh
and so it's an intense experience for
the performer
i think because you know it's a big
stage and you want to do great
and you're fighting certain elements
creatively and it just
it's just one of those things that i
think
is such a privilege and a blessing to be
able to experience
but then you realize oh this is why it's
the super bowl yeah
the big deal and uh and i'm just so glad
that everybody
you know at the end of the day enjoyed
the performance and love what we did
and uh i'm happy i'm happy that it's not
me this year and it's the weekend
in february uh jennifer you're gonna
have teenagers
i know
you got a precursor with natasha and
and 16 the other day you know
ella and and emmy and max are all the
same age so they're all going to be
teenagers next you know
early next year and it's it's crazy it's
just it goes so fast and again that's
why it's
about cherishing every day it's about
you know
cherishing yourself and your time
because it's precious
it's precious